well we took a leap of faith here we saw
that the scalloped onyx team had pulled
it off and so we work in a way for Jim
to finish that prototype before getting
the art the artist started on the art of
it his shells his leg structure his head
Jim's working on the skeleton and now
Rob and team are working on the skin now
we've got something that's a little bit
unique for a forearm character how do
you how do you balance all that out
because there was a point where we had
Bruce in the suit where you know your
eye was drawn to the small arms and you
were drawn to Bruce and you're
constantly trying to figure out it's
like okay I see it I see the guys like
and that's exactly what we didn't want
my first contribution was the arms to
cover up Bruce's arms in the suit we had
to disguise disguise his arms to look
like a robot obviously Rob and I
actually came up together I built him
but the three clawed arm on the right
hand
we came up with this drill bit idea this
is the kind of wacky or weird
same time it looks metal looks heavy
looks cool for those forearms we have
some designs and the right arm I think
stuck pretty close to the design left
arm changed quite a bit originally I
think he was a robotic hand but they
didn't just turning into a gun fans out
of nothing more than molded plastic
starts to cobble together these guns
that not only look dangerous but look
like they each weigh about 500 pounds
his right arm he has Gatling gun and on
his left arm some futuristic type of
laser double shotgun thing going on and
we left our Marvel has the microphone
which is interviewing the celebrities
down at Comic Con the guys have done a
great job and assembling all of this you
know and they know that there are these
particular that have to be addressed yet
but you know when you when you see it as
a whole you just kind of like know
there's certain areas they have to be
dealt with one of the biggest areas was
weight its things just kind of got too
top-heavy so we've had discussions and
we decided just to go in and just try to
trim a percentage off of all parts on
the upper part just to give Bruce more
mobility we decided to use a lot of
vacuform shells on the upper body the
time frame of the job was another
challenge we didn't have tons and tons
of time so vacuform was enable you to
generate shells quickly they're
lightweight they're pretty durable Jeff
deist and Damian Fisher quickly got to
creating some stone bucks that we could
run back you forms off of and the pieces
started to come together we didn't have
a lot of time tule mold
pieces for the vacuform bug so we took
the positives that we already had
you know played them up and corrected it
in stone as we went with ultra cows
although all the positives were all
DeKalb we'll be corrected it with blood
ultra calico Ted came in and he had some
foam structure that went into the vacuum
forms that definitely dampens for the
vacuum or so thin it's just like paper
bugs plastic so and you know putting
some ribbing that Ted did was really you
know helped a lot from that to just
really had focus on trying to keep the
weight as low as possible but also
needed to not be bouncy you know it
can't we want a lot of bounciness it
still had to look like a really robust
robots the model shop constructed the
the leg the legs for example are pretty
much the biggest things that we molded
on the project we molded one leg and one
leg activates both legs and the lower
legs we chose to use a different
material which could you know take on
all the punishment that the lower legs
are due to take by kicking chairs or
tables or bumping into things we knew
that we needed to design a head
ultimately people need something to lock
on to they need to recognize it it you
know you can't make it so alien or so
amorphous that that they can't connect
with it Darnell was prepping things and
then he had a few days to prepare the
face the face mask and we saw it on the
computer screen is like looks great
let's go for it
and so we printed the face no molding in
between and that's pretty important for
me because of that they somehow falls
off and breaks day of first day of Comic
Con
I have 35 hour turnaround you'll see a
lot of grills thin lines thin area
student walls and my main concern was to
make sure those areas of detail were not
too thin that my technology could not
reproduce in an ABS like material
so then legacies painters jumped in and
started making magic
Jamie Grove John cherub Garrick
rosengrant the vibe of the paint scheme
was uh it was kind of earthy tone no
kind of scheme going on battle damage
speed up the shoes would be dusty there
would be scrapes where the arms are
moving together if he's gotten a fight
you put dents and scratches and dirt wow
he's got mud on his feet it's like
where's he been you know what's he been
doing it's got rust it's got drippy
stains it's like you know it has a
backstory that you don't even have to
worry about telling it starts to tell
itself people start to fill in the
blanks it involves many techniques of
weathering and paint chipping and
you know the green the army the camo and
the shades going understand always I was
looking at books of tractors or tanks or
whatever to see how things where and
high points on on corners and things
would be the things that take the abuse
so we're applying all that stuff to our
paint techniques and just kind of the
general aesthetic of this characters
yeah it pulls everybody every time we've
done stuff this
styrene involvement it looks like
drill-press heart or something then
after that I kind of made my move into
doing a lot of the bracketing a lot of
mounting of the shells getting
everything actually up there physically
up so we could start seeing what the
structure of the robot was going to look
like on the size and everything head
mounting working with pond and just
getting kind of all the artwork in the
shells around the Khans mechanism and
then you know just getting it dialed in
and getting it locked up getting in the
right spot